and here to tell us more is the director
of the Institute of Virology at the
Charity Hospital here in Berlin deadlift
kluger will come to tomorrow today now
how come there are no approved phage
therapies here in Germany's despite the
fact that we're searching so urgently
for new weapons against these resistant
germs the point is that for many years
the research on bacteriophages was quite
undeveloped features played an important
role in the development of science in
the middle of the previous century or as
a model of for normal for animal and
human viruses there was even research in
Germany on phages here the world 30s
there was yeah and unfortunately zoo
scientists and emigrated to the United
States or to other countries and so via
but we had also hate research after the
war in Germany before that was a time
where the modern molecular biology
developed and so modern biology develop
and fitch was an important model to
understand such processes but now we
actually are in a situation with big big
problems with these resistant germs we
have about 10,000 to 30,000 dead people
every year and we heard that President
Obama actually announced to invest 1.2
billion dollar in the research to fight
these germs and well research be able to
leave out phage therapy so i think we
now we have to remember that's odd ideas
at phage destroy bacteria and that could
be used for therapeutic purposes that
was an original idea even off sin in of
the people who investigated and found it
bacteriophages about 100 years ago and
their first idea was okay the
bacteriophage means it it eats bacteria
and so they can use it for political
approaches to for therapy of bacteria
that was forgotten because then
and the antibiotics came up and that was
a very at golden time of antibiotics
very useful but now you have a new era
in the development now we are facing the
multi resistant bacteria and now we have
to look for not only for the development
of new antibiotics that's also very
important and that is how come how come
pharmaceutical industry is not really
investing I mean we heard that they're
not doing anything about antibiotics
probably because it's hard to get a
return on investments there I mean could
you make money with the phage therapies
as it could make money of course but I
think the first step should be some
basic research again and to remember
this all data and then to look and then
to solve such problems how to apply a
phage we have no bacteria in our
organism which are solely only present
but they have always a microenvironment
we call it a biofilm and via one of the
critical points is how the phage can
penetrate that biofilm and meets a
bacterium to destroy all such questions
have to be solved but I think in case
that one would invest really and that
field of sands it could be done and I
hope in a very short time so we're
looking forward for that research and
for new therapies thanks a lot for the
talk if clicker